foreign
Pennsylvania what's up Claire how we
doing
excited to talk to you this is so
exciting I'm excited to talk to you
what's happening
um okay so I had a baby nine weeks ago
congratulations and thank you
um and since then I have been so annoyed
with my husband
everything
like the first two weeks I actually
think I hated him yeah everything he did
just oh I made my skin crawl I just had
this like visceral reaction it was
terrible and what I'm laughing with you
not at you like so no what was he doing
what was he doing
well so that's what made it worse is he
was doing everything like he was being
so good he was like helping with the
baby and like he was keeping the house
clean like he did nothing wrong okay and
yet I still was like I just had this uh
I was just so annoyed
um and so you know that was like the
first couple weeks and since then it's
gotten a lot better okay but I'm still
like
I don't know I still get very annoyed
when
just I guess at him in general and again
it's like for no reason like he's still
he's an amazing husband and I like
logically I know like I'm so grateful
but just I just can't like shake these
feelings of just annoyance
um so and I'm sick of it like I really
want to feel loving for my husband again
um
but and you know like we have such good
communication like he knows how I'm
feeling and we've talked about it so
much and talking about it does help but
like I still have these like lingering
feelings of annoyance and I really want
to get rid of them so
one uh number one you're awesome thank
you for
you just you just clarified what
millions of new moms feel and experience
in a very clear and concise way so thank
you for doing that okay that's
comforting that it's not just me you're
not insane no okay
um
I'm trying to think where to where
annoyance doesn't mean you don't love
him number one don't equate those two
things
number two
feelings are very very important and
they lie to you
and part of dealing with a new body a
new life you have a kid now with a new
husband because he's a new guy he's got
a child he's the same dude looks the
same smells the same leaves his
underwear in the same pile totally
different totally different guy now
right so yeah yeah it doesn't mean you
love him
it means y'all got to build something
completely new now I want to ask you
something you have to tell me the truth
you promise
I promise okay I promise
I don't fully believe you so convince me
there's something he's doing that's
driving me crazy what is it
yeah
okay go for it okay so what when we got
home from the hospital
he was like I think he was and we
listened to him anyway he was like
trying to be super dead I think and I
felt like the only thing I was doing was
nursing the baby and then he would take
the baby and change the baby and play
with it's like you know and put the baby
down and everything and like at first I
think I felt like I like was being
robbed of like
being his mom kind of does that make any
sense at all a thousand percent it does
okay so
um like I said like we had talked about
that and like we've sort of just a
couple days ago we kind of had the
conversation about like our new roles
like what his role as dad looks like and
like what my role as mom looks like and
it's been much better since then but I
think that was the thing that sort of
like Set It Off is just like I felt like
like I have been like looking forward to
being a mom like my whole adult life so
I was so excited to have the baby and
then it felt like all I was doing was
feeding the baby which of course is
important but like I wanted to do all
the other things too and so what you ran
into a super common thing you've heard
me talk about this a million times on
the show you had a very distinct picture
of what mom was going to be
and you had a picture of what dad was
going to be
and he had a very distinct picture of
what being a dad was going to be like
and what your role as a mom was going to
be like
and both of you went into that with the
greatest of motives in the highest love
for one another and for that little baby
and you just pass each other in the
night because you had different
you used words and the words were mom
and dad but the pictures of what that
looked like were very different
yeah right and so all we have to do is
align here's what dad's gonna mean for
us
here's what Mom is going to mean for us
and then we're gonna live into that
picture your husband sounds like an
awesome guy who was like I'm not going
to be that Dad
who just sits there watching football
I'm going to be this and you sound like
an awesome Mom who was I want to
experience all of this I've carried this
knucklehead for nine months I want to
experience all of it all the and I don't
want to be that Mom that's like whining
about her husband all the time and then
in an effort to love each other great
y'all forgot to ask each other what that
meant
all right now you're frustrated you're
annoyed with him whatever okay so
let your annoyance not be something
you're scared of let it be a
um traffic signal
just giving you a heads up that there's
probably something you haven't spoken
out loud yet
and you will find if you speak something
out loud and your husband does something
you won't be frustrated or annoyed
you'll be pissed all right your body
will let you know I specifically said I
am changing diapers and he's like I
changed all the diapers right you'll be
angry you won't be annoyed annoyance is
usually me not speaking my boundaries
and somebody Crossing them and not
knowing they crossed them
okay so I just have to figure out what
that is exactly and so ask yourself with
joy with a smile on your face ask
yourself what's my body trying to tell
me right now what is he doing right now
that I would like to be doing
but you see how important it is to be
curious and not judgmental
yes just be curious about it I oh man
I'm starting to be really annoyed at
that dude
it's because he's singing and I want I
had a picture of quiet tonight all you
have to do is say hey can I have
like I've been listening to this baby
cry all day can we have some quiet and
he'll go oh yeah sure right I know and
he will you know like I don't really
will if I just asked him he would he
would do anything you know okay so now
you're in how long have y'all been
married
uh three years okay you're in you're in
part two
congratulations you just went to level
two in marriage
all right
yeah it was a big jump
oh and they don't tell you what it is
any of his stuff
right but here's here's what part two
means part two means before you had baby
y'all could just make out whenever you
wanted wherever you wanted you could
just spend whatever dumb money you
wanted on whatever dinner you want you
could just wake up at midnight and be
like okay you just want to go eat ice
cream be like yeah let's do that
now your life is different you can't do
that anymore
or you can once a year right and then
you just get gassy when you eat ice
cream in the middle of the night it's
not even worth it
so so nothing has changed and everything
has changed
and so instead of getting home at 5 pm
and him being able to just nod his head
to you across the room and you know oh
gosh he wants to hook up again and we're
just gonna do it now you got to put on
the calendar
right now instead of just leaving the
room because he's singing
now you got a baby and you can't just
get up and leave the room you got to
tell them hey please stop singing
so now we're going to be more
intentional about letting our needs be
heard and that takes a lot more risk
because when you let our needs be heard
the our partner can say no I'm not doing
that and so it's more vulnerable As you
move up levels it becomes more
vulnerable see what I'm saying yeah yeah
so I feel like I'm not great at speaking
my needs anyway so none of us are none
of us are right and so you're going to
practice it but it's letting him know
hey I am going to start speaking my
needs and I want you to start speaking
your needs and this is going to be
awkward and weird for both of us
do you
and you are gonna instantly be filled up
with Shame about it
I can't believe you had to ask me for
this or you're going to be filled up
with anger did you know what I'm doing
every day and you have to commit to not
letting those feelings you can feel them
it's fine but they're not telling you
the truth
and you're gonna have to say okay he
husband did what he said he was gonna do
he's expected his needs now I get to
decide whether I'm going to meet those
needs and how and then you got to do the
same thing for him
yeah right
yeah no it makes sense an annoyance is
just a signal it's just a signal
okay good you're not you're not getting
scared by my annoyance so I'm glad that
oh no no no you're not broken you're not
broken at all right usually I thought
you were gonna say this usually when I
talk to
you you're nine nine weeks or nine
months
nine weeks okay nine weeks as to
it's used about month three or four that
husbands are like well when are we gonna
start hooking up again you know I mean
and and so that's usually when people
are like I'm super annoyed with him like
I just I am I want my body back I'm
feeding a kid my body's still trying to
get back into its original shape now
this guy's Pawling at me I just want all
right you're not there yet possibly but
you'll be there soon
he's giving me some looks and I've kind
of shot him down
that's right that's right so that's yeah
so it will morph from look to
so uh right and so here's the deal
let's commit now to speaking our needs
out loud
and really his need for like his like
dude when are we gonna that's really
often code for I miss my wife
um
and that's different than I just want to
get off like right see what I'm saying
so we're just going to be curious we're
going to be not judgmental with each
other and we're going to practice
speaking our needs out loud and then by
the way you're gonna have all kinds of
banana feelings it's all good you know
what else you're gonna feel really
annoyed at that kid
and then you know what you're gonna feel
really guilty that you felt annoyed yeah
and then you're gonna feel really
shameful that you felt guilty though
it's just uh that's all it's and it's
all it's all lies it never ends
and that's part of the fun right it's
part of the fun yeah it's super annoying
to bring us full circle
so Claire you're a great mom
thank you great wife
and you're just in level two and you
just gotta do you're gonna have to learn
new skills in this one and by the way
you're gonna have another kid and he's
gonna get a new job and then you're
gonna think about going back to work or
not going back to work and then you're
gonna go to level three and this whole
thing keeps moving right yeah yeah so
I'll leave you with this the great
Esther perel says
the average adult has four or five great
loves in their lifetime in their adult
lifetime
and if they work really hard it's with
the same person
but I am not the guy my wife married not
even close that guy was in
and I'm not who I was 15 years ago thank
goodness I'm not who it was 10 years ago
I'm especially not who I was five years
ago four years ago especially not
so all that to say is
my wife has had to keep
okay I'm now married to this guy
I'm now married to this guy I am not
married to this guy and I've had to do
the same thing with her
she's a radically different woman than
the person I married
and so the the adventure and excitement
and joy of marriage is
what do you need how can I make help
meet your needs and here's what I need
that's not what you needed last season
you're right it's a new season now just
like in the summer I need shorts and a
t-shirt and a winner I need a coat and
jacket I'm still the same guy my needs
just changed and that happens all the
time and if you can unhook from this is
the way quote unquote is supposed to be
this I'm supposed to feel and this is
what is oh man now you're in for a
for an incredible Adventure with a
partner
on to wherever y'all end up
and that my friend Claire that's the
magic
that's the magic